we started the the first hour with our
New Year's resolutions from our uh from
our audience but now we've got one from
uh well from Joe Biden he says his New
Year's resolution is well let's
see what's your New Year's
resolution anything else that's the
biggest one right
now do you say to come back come back
next year and and you know we don't know
if he means back to Saint Croy for New
Year or may back to
life I back to the White House
Consciousness it's an odd thing back to
the White House yeah it could be back to
that
restaurant that fancy restaurant he was
at could be anything back to his nap
nobody knows and that's the point um and
a lot of people are really critical of
the fact that he's on vacation in St
Croy at this luxury home of a
billionaire anyway um because as you
know we have hotpots all over the
country all over the world um that we
wish he was you know at the helm taking
charge of and and especially at our
border I want to show you this um map
here look at his face it's just it's it
is it's true it's like you're the the
oldest guy you know in your neighborhood
like just yelling at
you anyway sorry sorry no no no no no I
I I think that that that image has a lot
to do with this image um just this
feeling that nobody's in charge um that
they've Unleashed this policy on us and
and and maybe it's not going the way
they want maybe it's too much but they
don't seem to care um look at this
286,000 migrant encounters since
December for 1 770,000 migrant
encounters since October 1st um that's
85 thou
83,500 known Goda ways and look I mean
look at those states there that's those
are some records there oh yeah no
question no question about it and the
total number of reported encounters um
are greater than the population of those
15 states so this is going to Happ
that's staggering it's staggering and I
think it's really hard to think about
just how this is going to have an impact
well into the future I mean social
services are already strained but these
people are going nowhere they will will
be here permanently I don't think
anyone's going to deport them and so
what does that mean for your school your
hospital unless taxes unless Donald
Trump wins and puts in the
administration he says he will which
they say hey we will Deport these people
a lot of people to deport you know it
would be a massive backlash but you
would have the legal standing to do so
and you need to have the hutzpah to do
so uh but you we just can't to your
point Rachel you just can't sustain that
that many people and you got a year
longer of this Joey you mentioned it
those are record numbers so those
numbers we showed were basically based
on a month the first one 286,000 in a
month and then a quarter 800,000 in a
quarter and this these are the known
Goda ways let alone the ones we don't
know about I mean these known Goda ways
is such a misleading nomenclature for
something so what do known Goda ways
mean does it mean these are the amount
of people we saw on a camera but didn't
intercept or is is it a prediction of
what they think the total people that
came across the border they didn't
intercept I don't care about known Goda
ways I want to know about unknown Goda
ways how many people are are coming
across the border that we have no
interaction with that are coming here
freely and and that number is
speculative at best it's probably huge
and it really tells the rest of the
story I mean the bid Administration has
taken this crazy notice to appear piece
of paper and if you hand that to someone
and say hey we've documented that you
came here illegally you're asking for
Asylum we can't make that determination
right now so we're going to let you on
in just please come back in 2 to 4 years
and we'll have a court case and figure
it out that makes through the through
the Biden Administration that makes
their presence in this country legalish
that gives them documentation actually
of of why the B Administration is
allowing them to be here although they
came here completely illegally and have
no proven claim to be here so you know
Joey uh first of all by the end of this
uh Joe Biden's term I believe we're
going to have about 10 million people
who will have come into this country
illegally that's a massive um number of
people especially if you think about
that these are people with you know low
skills not a lot of Education um and we
don't know who they are and and what's
going on yesterday I had a guest on that
I interviewed on this show and he was an
um I want to maybe our producers can
remember his name and but but in any
case he said listen this is no longer in
my opinion I can't figure out what the
endgame is I used to think it was about
votes that these were they were
importing uh you know potential Democrat
voters future voters but he said I this
is so much bigger than that I would say
so much more coordinated than that with
um organizations like the world economic
Forum the UN the Soros funded Nos and
many of these um other countries
so the end game to me is a borderless
world um it is about collapsing our
system in fact that guest said I have to
believe this is about destroying our
country because there's no other
explanation for it the vote the the
future voters thing doesn't work anymore
it doesn't make sense anymore uh which
which would mean looking at the pictures
of Joe Biden on vacation giving a
nonsense New Year's Eve resolution uh
it's not that he's incompetence that
he's party to it yeah he's party I mean
he's willing to see that destruction
under his watch and do nothing about it
uh and that's what representative Randy
Weber republican from Texas uh he gave a
quote to Fox News digital about this
contrast and he said President Biden's
der elction of Duty is on Full display
while he sits on the beach and ignores
the thousands of illegal immigrants
invading our country daily America as we
know it will be unrecognizable unless
this Administration comes to the table
starts enforcing the laws and stops the
flow of illegal immigrants which of
course they won't which is why the
election will be such a referendum on
you know the economy on this issue and
then of course everything the left wants
to make it about too I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis